dieses statement sorgt heute tatsächlich
für wirbel für schlagzeilen für
kopfschütteln wirtschaftsminister robert
habeck ist am abend bei maischberger und
das was er zu drohenden insolvenzen sagt
also zu betrieben die vor der pleite
stehen das ist teilweise wirklich absurd
main einige warum werden mal rein
das kriegen wir jetzt überall das leben
die darauf angewiesen sind dass die
menschen geld ausgeben blumenläden
bioläden leckereien gehören dazu dass
die wirkliche probleme haben weil ist
eine kaufzurückhaltung gibt und dann
sind die nicht insolvent automatisch
aber sie hören vielleicht auf zu
verkaufen und du hast nicht aufhöre zu
verkaufen und verdiene ich kein geld
mehr da muss ich die insolvenz anmelden
nach zwei monaten wenn dies nicht getan
habe habe ich würde man würde dann
insolvent werden wenn man mit der arbeit
immer größeres minus macht ja aber wie
würde denn kein größeres minus machen
wenn sie leute bezahlen aber dies wir
verkaufen also
wie soll man also ich hab es nicht
verstehe ich weiß doch automatisch eine
insolvenzwelle geben geben muss aber es
kann sein dass ich bestimmte geschäfte
nicht mehr rentieren und hier dann
eingestellt werden vielleicht werden sie
spielt er wieder aufgenommen das kann ja
sein also das ist dann ja keine
klassische insolvenz aber es kann sein
wenn wir keine abhilfe schaffen dass die
betriebe dakar ein handwerksbetriebe
reinigungsfirmen und so weiter über
dieses jahr dann die wirtschaftliche
betätigung einstellen das ist eine
gefahr und der müssen wir begegnen
bei uns im studio begrüßen wir jetzt
wirtschaftsexperten kai warnecke keramik
wie haben sie den
bundeswirtschaftsminister wahrgenommen
was gibt ja in ihren augen dort für eine
figur ab ich bin ehrlich gesagt ziemlich
schockiert ein wirtschaftsminister der
offensichtlich unterstellt dass zum
beispiel der bäcker einfach sechs monate
lang zu machen kann man völlig losgelöst
von dem technischen terminus der
insolvenz und dann einfach wieder
aufmacht und genug geld hat ein halbes
jahr zu überbrücken gleichzeitig aber
extrem gestiegenen energiepreise
bezahlen musste er kennt die menschen in
diesem land nicht und er kennt
offensichtlich auch die wirtschaft in
diesem lande nicht das wirkt doch sehr
auf mich als wäre er nicht sehr geeignet
für den job kann er es noch so ist er
überfordert ihrer meinung nach das ist
eine spannende frage also wenn man die
energiepreise allein betrachtet da muss
man ja sagen er ist eigentlich die
ursache der explodierenden energiepreise
weil er die energie in deutschland
verknappt indem er verschiedene
energiequellen vom markt nimmt das führt
zu steigenden preisen und der
überfordert damit die bürgerinnen und
bürger die tatsache dass er das jahr
verursacht lässt eigentlich nur den
schluss zu dass auch nicht willens ist
diese situation wieder zu beheben und
die situation zu beheben ist ein gutes
stichwort wir haben nämlich heute auf
bild.de eine umfrage gemacht und sie
gefragt ob sie glauben dass
bundeswirtschaftsminister uns durch die
krise bringt ja und das ergebnis ist
sehr eindeutig 93 prozent der menschen
die abgestimmt haben sagen nein harbeck
bringt uns nicht durch die krise und nur
7 prozent glauben noch an seine gabe als
politiker
das ist in der tat ein schockierendes
resultat das sich sicherlich auch robert
mal zu herzen nehmen muss wenn er die
wirtschaft so wenig kennt und die
situation zum beispiel von handwerkern
wie ein bäckermeister der vielleicht
auch noch in seinem haus eine wohnung
hat dir vermieten soll selber wohnt er
produziert jetzt leerstand in den
innenstädten unser sozialleben berichte
in der folge zusammen er kann vielleicht
für sich selber der bäckermeister nicht
mehr die energie port kosten bezahlen
die er für sich brauchen werden eine
wohnung vermietet wird auch noch
verpflichtet in seinem haus für den
mieter die energiekosten zu tragen also
da ist auch für die immobilienbranche
und für das normale handwerk überhaupt
kein verständnis da eigentlich das
schlechteste wirtschaftsminister den ich
bisher so erlebt habe was halten sie
denn vom beschlossenen entlastungspaket
der ampel das sind leistungspakete ist
eigentlich so ein bisschen ein
stückwerk das hier und da mal
funktionieren könnte vielleicht an
vielen stellen nicht funktionieren wird
und insbesondere ist es da um die eigene
klientel ein wenig zu bedienen aber was
soll denn jemand mit 300 euro mehr haben
wenn er zwei 3000 euro mehr ausgaben für
energie hat das rechnet sich hinten und
vorne nicht und die meisten menschen in
diesem land haben eben nicht die
geldsummen die man braucht um das zu
kompensieren der kanzler hat vorhin
gesagt you never walk alone wieder sein
anspruch der bezahlt haben auch keine
rechnungen was für lösungen hätten sie
also das erste was wir mit blick auf die
energie machen müssen ist mehr energie
zu besorgen denn wenn wir ausreichend
energie haben werden automatisch die
preise fallen und das ist der allererste
schritt das ist eigentlich die
kernaufgabe des
bundeswirtschaftsministers und
angesichts der situation glaube ich das
ist die kernaufgabe der gesamten
regierung ist auch von olaf scholz und
wenn man dann den spruch dazu hört
you'll never walk alone ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen da fühle ich mich schon
ein bisschen verarscht wenn ich das man
so deutlich sagen darf denn die menschen
werden allein gelassen mit dem aber die
frage diese energie das problem der
energiekrise bis zum winter zu lösen da
haben wir nicht mehr viel zeit für uns
läuft die zeit davon ich bin jetzt auch
kein experte für einzelne kraftwerks
arten aber ich glaube wir müssen
wirklich jeden versuch unternehmen alles
was wir haben in betrieb zu halten zu
nutzen wir sind in einem europäischen
verbund unserer europäischen nachbarn
sind mittlerweile alle erzürnt also wir
verschaffen ja auch der europäischen
union und den nachbarländern gewaltige
probleme und wenn wir da nicht zusammen
stehen und alles unternehmen um genug
energie zur verfügung zu haben dann
haben wir ein echtes problem zumal ich
derzeit nicht sehr dass sich der krieg
in der ukraine schnell erledigt und die
situation dann wieder bereinigt sagt kai
warnecke präsident von haus und grund
und wirtschaftsexperte herzlichen dank
für das gespräch sehr gerne
[Musik]